si j'emploie devoir c'est parce que
j'aime le noir c'est pas tellement un
souci de contrôle qui me qui me fait
choisir le noir c'est un souci
d'intensité d'intensité sur le plan
plastique mais aussi sur l'arrière-plan
qui est finalement elle la qualité
poétique que l'on peut tirer de certains
contrastes certaine opposition de
certains passages tableau en noir et
blanc
quand on quand on le voit sur un mur
il exclut les couleurs qui l'entourent
[Musique]
quand on se déplace devant la toile
alternativement le même point et blanc
ou noir a forcément blancs c'est
l'épreuve a attiré par la lumière qu'on
projette dessus 2 à 7 devant devant la
mer des toiles est souvent très bleu
[Musique]
moi je travaille pas par désir par
plaisir de peindre par besoin
d'interroger ce que recèle la peinture
que je suis en train de faire mais c'est
toujours ce que je fais qui m'apprend ce
que je cherche
[Musique]